In 2011, Australian HL7 standards guru,
Grahame Grieve, proposed a new interoperability approach
he called Resources for Healthcare or RFH.
He said that it would define a set of resources to represent
granular clinical concepts for use on their own or aggregated into complex documents.
In other words it would be composable so that unlike with complex CCDA documents,
developers could request only the information needed for their particular use case.
In part because of that he said this flexibility could
offer coherent solutions for a range of interoperability problems.
He went on to say that technically RFH is designed for the web.
The resources are based on simple XML with
an HTTP based restful protocol where each resource has a predictable URL,
where possible open internet standards are used for data representation.
Later that year the HL7 board authorized a fresh look task force to
examine the best way to create
interoperability solutions with no preconditions on what those solutions might be.
The idea was not to start all over but that based on prior attempts
by HL7 and other groups the task force would consider new approaches to interoperability.
Grahame joined the effort and at its outset hosted several key questions on his blog.
What are we trying to do?
What do our customers want?
What exchanges are we trying to serve?
Are we doing syntax or semantics?
Does the market even wants semantics?
HL7 has two quite different stakeholders in vendors and large healthcare programs.
Can they agree on what they want?
Grahame ended up leading the resulting standards development effort renamed
Fast Healthcare Interoperability Resources or F-H-I-R, FHIR.
We've touched on FHIR throughout the earlier parts of this course.
Now we will look at it in more detail.